Vivian Springford's career has long defied any category of art.
A 1932 debutante, Springford skirted expectations and instead went to art school.
For over a decade, she would work as a figurative painter and teacher...
...before making the turn to abstract expressionism.
Springford's inspiration came from what was around her...
...and ranged from Asian art and Taoist calligraphy...
...to perhaps most recognizably nature.
Her layered and vibrant pools of saturated color...
...are both a result of intention and chance.
She'd drip paint over the canvas, then tilt and tip it to create bursts of color.
In one of her final bodies of work, known as the Scuba series,...
...we see an artist fully harnessing the emotive power of color.
Expressive, meditative and moving,...
...Vivian Springford's intricately, delicate work brings a fresh perspective...
...to the world of abstraction.